so killing the unbeliever and all that
kind of stuff You' been heavily
brainwashed that's why I'm going to help
you it say those things in the Quran
heavily brainwashed because I mean look
at all this happening in the world we
all see it thank you there you there you
go there you go there you go you see
majority happens out here is by Muslims
though you're an islamophobe man I just
read it to you in your believe Samuel I
just read it to you why you scared I can
reach my samel okay thank you man oh my
go I mean I don't know how much I'm
reading cuz he asked me youone I don't
get the point can you read just just a
few more lines few more lines I read you
two lines already want say two more
lines he's changed Samuel now where is
it going go back to Samuel go back to
Samuel man there's only one more verse
you can read that last verse read it why
are you afraid to read it what do you
mean I already read two no you didn't
read the last two okay you said you said
three right where is it at was
15 brothers and sisters just imagine for
a second that you give £10 in donation
and that £10 is used to buy food or
bricks or whatever to help the people in
Gaza but then just imagine this amazing
D that you want to do but we turn it
into a money-making machine house
the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subhana bless and preserve you
guys it's because what's your name
what's your name Jude Jude my name is
Ali nice meet you yeah appreciate from
you're from you're from you're from
America no sir oh you where you from I'm
from Haiti oh Haiti oh interesting okay
okay so now you made a claim you said
that in an Islamic country you will not
be able to do this no you can and I
agree with you yeah no no no no that's
that's that's a bit you know the S you
know the movie Saw You know the saw yeah
I think I don't like horror mov yeah I'm
saying You must be watching a horror
movie you must be watching a horror
movie to say that cuz no they do though
no they don't they don't kill they don't
kill Christians if they out here
preaching like the gospel they don't in
a Muslim CH no they don't no no there's
no way in the Islam on the Shar that
says that you kill a Christian person
for preaching so killing the unbeliever
and all that kind of stuff you've been
heavily brainwashed that's why I'm going
to help it say those things in the Quran
heavily brainwashed heavily brainwashed
you know why this shows me that heavily
brainwash heavily heavily heavily that's
the reason why I switch Street straight
away because there's certain things you
said and I was like okay this sounds
familiar so the point is this um you are
making claims now about um that is a
capital punishment there is no evidence
you don't know I never about you number
one anything about don't put words what
are you guys disagreeing about something
about capital punishment I never said
anything you said that he said something
you guys discussing something about
capital punishment you said you said if
a Christian does this he'll be killed
that's capital punishment he they me he
mentioned capital punishment and all I
said was if a Christian a Muslim country
they will be killed good I never said
capital punishment that's putting words
in my mouth killed is capital punishment
capital punishment so so that's what
they do in Muslim countries yes or no so
I'm just saying you did it is capital
punishment killing is capital punishment
I didn't say that they do it in the US
China as well it's not just Muslim
country I know capital punishment saying
if a Christian is out in a Muslim
country preaching the gospel he'll
probably be killed okay so what I'm
saying is what I'm saying is not
necessarily what I'm saying is might go
to prison I'm saying what I'm saying is
could be in a prison country and do that
I'm not trying to cut you off
he all right if you say that you that
one second I'm just saying a capital
punishment can go up to killing so
that's what I was saying when you you
didn't say word for word capital
punishment but you said they'll be
killed and that is a capital punishment
not always good so what I'm saying is
the following I mean putting the
electric shair is is a capital
punishment exactly that's what I'm
saying so what I'm saying is where did
you get this from what cutting the head
of all the unbelievers and all that yeah
exactly it's not in the Quran no it's
not all right some of the brothers here
to find it I have Quan here but like
that but but then why are you making
claims that you cannot substantiate
because I mean look at all that's
happening in the world we all see it one
second one second one second look at all
the terrorists yeah from Israel from
Iraq 1 million people killed uh for
example in Afghanistan what the US for
example what happen in Bosnia what's
happening in the Burma so so so by by by
who who I mean who's going up the world
TR a number one let me tell you me
expert I'm just ask a question I just
ask a question we can already see you're
not an expert I I even say I even say me
no I'm not ins to you because then you
go over there so man you're expert one
tongue and then you go pray with another
tongue all right cool that's true I'm
going to go pray us in a minute and I'm
also going to tell you that you're I'm
not insulting you I'm I didn't call you
idiot when I say idiot I didn't say say
anid it's not factual that that if a
Christian is preaching the gospel that
he'll be killed said not
necessarily
brother
of guys guys if you can have one person
number one did I call him an idiot did
anyone hear me call him an idiot I
didn't call him an idiot I never see I
said you're not a scholar okay so what
I'm saying is now you're coming with
language which is it sounds very
islamophobic I'll be I'll be very honest
with you yeah you've come here you've
come here and I agree one second you've
been
super
saying so somebody a question orob
so when I said so I in in Islam
christianr question guys guys guys guys
we can't have a fruitful discussion the
same sorry sorry sorry before before you
come and say a
Muslim before you come and say a Muslim
tried to hit me I mean okay thank you
there there you go there you go there
you go you see majority happens out here
is by Muslims though you're an Islam
man I need I need look at you in the
eyes man you are a fullblown ISL let me
tell you something let me tell you how
let me tell you how now the amount the
greatest people who have killed the mass
amount of people yes is number one
atheist number two yes yes yes yes yes
mosang yes okay Stalin the World War I
World War II please World War 3 that's
going to start now Christianity is
second or third on the list so before
you come to me with any of that I want
because you've come to me with this
attitude one second no problem no no I'm
going to tell you something can you so
when I find
I'm going to give you a simple question
you're a Christian yeah you're a
Christian J I'm you believe in Jesus
Christ yet okay if you truly believe in
Jesus Christ let me ask you a simple
question yeah I dare and challenge you I
will give you £1,000 right now for my
own money yeah show me it's I don't say
about money I'm the point is this show
me a verse the one that you have in your
Bible 1st Samuel 15: 2-3 which is 1st
Samuel 15 vers 2-3 old testament which
is the god of who's the god of the Old
Testament Jesus he say wa wait wait wait
wait wait wait hold on hold on
not even created yet or born yet so how
how are you you know what I'm saying so
so is Jesus do you believe in the
Trinity I believe in the father Son and
the Holy Spirit the father Son and the
Holy Spirit okay is Jesus God yes okay
who was the god of the Old
Testament who is the god of the old test
yes Jehovah sorry Jehovah ja Yahweh
Elohim okay elim yah okay no problem
Jesus Is
God God for a second though cuz no no no
no that's cool start for a second
oh yeah can you find me a scure where
says tell some of the
boys I'm coming back I'm coming back to
you so uh the the god of the Old
Testament uh you know that the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit right you
know they they existed in the Old
Testament right no problem so I'm saying
I'm just saying I'm just saying you
believe in the Triune God do you believe
in the Triune God yeah I believe the
father has it has it trying God have
always been there yes good you know you
read the Bible right yeah so you read
the Bible right I just going to start
from the beginning though so cuz just
just so you know the Trinity is real
before before we start anything upse
because I know what you going to go at
the Trinity not real I'm saying your oh
yes it is you believe God has a spirit
do you believe God has a spirit yes or
no you read the Bible I don't believe
God okay you said read read the Bible
you don't believe in the Bible I'll read
to you the first the first one I'll read
to you the first first in the beginning
right God created the heavens and the
Earth and the Earth was without form and
void and darkness was on the face of the
deep and the spirit of of God was
hovering yeah I don't believe in that
book
you there's no discuss then why you
going to talk about Samuel then going
back to the Old Testament Judah Judah
Judah Judah listen listen listen listen
this guy's going to teach you some few
things today so now you saying I said do
you believe in the Triune God you said
yeah I'm ask I believe that God's word
is eternal no problem I'm just saying to
you who is the god of the Old Testament
was it not Jesus I I already said that
already three times okay the triying god
are is it not the same God the old test
I just showed you that he the Holy
Spirit and God and Jesus all there at
the same time thank you okay now cool
who was so you're going to say to me who
Ed who sent 1 Samuel 15: 2-3 who what 1
Samuel 15: back to the Old Testament
read was it was it actually physically
on Earth yet can you read it I don't
care if he was Earth or not was he there
was he there did was he there I just
said his body wasn't there brother open
first chit where you going at now don't
worry where I'm going I'm going through
a nice place CU first off I was reading
the scripture you said you don't want
you don't you don't believe in this why
am I going to read it to you now for the
people that don't you just ask me I read
you something you didn't believe it and
now you ask me to go back to it read it
to you okay you're going to read
the to you do you believe in the
Quran uh I believe it's kind of false
okay good so but you're going to now
read the scripture from the read from
the Quran to thank you but that's what
I'm saying I'm not going to say well you
don't believe I read from the Quran and
it shows that Jesus is the word of God
and proceeds from we accept Jesus as the
word of God we never said we don't what
you going to go is was Jesus was Jesus
born or created no listen I'm saying I'm
asking you to open the Bible you say why
moral and all that kind guys sorry sorry
my bad you're telling me you are asking
me to open the Bible but Ali you don't
believe in the Bible I'm like yes I'm
you're going to open the Quran but you
don't believe in the Quran I just read
you the Bible you didn't say can you
open 1 Samuel CH 15 we already discussed
about the tri God right and I tried to
show you that the spirit of God already
existed you say you don't believe that
and I showed you it you said you don't
trust in the Bible so why am I going to
read the scripture to you again let me
let me make an example read it to
yourself I can read from the Quran where
it says that Jesus the word of God pro
from him I'm going to give example God's
word is eternal that means Jesus always
was there right okay I'm going to give
you an example of what you're doing to
me Allah says in the Quran it is not
look look it is not for anyone that he
believes except with the will of Allah
do you believe this I trust in the Lord
with all thy heart I Le not into my own
understanding in all my ways I
acknowledge Him He directs my path do
you thank you very much but do you
believe that was scripture you don't
even come on just gu man you know the
Quran so well I'll read to you where it
says that Jesus is the word of God and
proceeds from him brother I'm not even
talking about that can you just hear me
you're listening to reply you're
listening to reply you're not listening
to learn I'm saying I just read the
Quran do you believe these texts is from
God or not no thank you but we read it
together so I'm saying can I read your
Bible together even though I don't
believe in it I just read it to you in
your believe Samuel I just read it to
you why you scared I can reach my samel
okay thank you man
no problem Old Testament remember I said
that guys no problem Jesus wasn't in
there yet yeah he he need to give
disclaimers now CU he knows what's
coming I mean yeah I mean trying God of
course yeah he knows what's coming I'm
talking about physical body because
because you came with that attitude of
hostility and islamophobia and terrorism
and all that kind stuff we're going to
see you're going to see real terrorism
now psychology typ you're going to come
we're going to see what real terrorism
is now 1 Samuel 15:2 to3 chapter
15 the book that he doesn't trust that
he says corrupted 100%
[Music]
okay 15 what verse 2 to 3 you can read
from verse one it say uh Samuel also
said to
Saul wait out Saul right right David
killed 10,000 Saul killed a th just
remember that oh yeah sorry I'm reading
all right the Lord the Lord sent me the
Lord sent me to anoint the king over his
people am I continue reading what am I
reading this for just kind of read up to
verse oh Israel yeah which is the people
yeah uh now now therefore he the voice
of the word which is Jesus yeah yeah
which is Jesus right yeah um uh the
where am I reading second one sorry
sorry I got lost my the word of the Lord
uh thus says the Lord of hosts um I will
punish who is that almanac for for for
he did his uh for he did it to his
Israel did is yeah my English is
terrible me trust me I mean mam couldn't
read right
uh no I don't need go uh but I mean I
don't know how much I'm reading cuz he
asked
me I don't get the point can you read
just just a few more lines few more
lines read a few more lines all that
says the Lord host I will punish alak
for what he did is to Israel how he um
ambushed him um are you talking about
revenge um on the way when he came up to
Egypt no because you're talking about
revenge because if you read if you read
if you read the chapters before on if
you read the chapters before these
people attacked the Israelites the
Israelites were going back and God is
telling them go and attack them back so
there's context so there's context when
he says in the Quran he says kill this
stuff there's no context there's context
now carry on
you about in the oldest last two lines
telling the people of Israel to go back
and kill the people Jesus telling them
read it read it read it brother read it
read it you read it done you done it's
going to get funny you talk about
revenge it's going to get funnier so
wait wait wait hold on hold on hold on
wait wait wait cuz look you reading this
context right here right but you're not
going back to read what happened before
you reading why are the people of Israel
are going to go kill you no no no no no
it's telling you for Revenge because of
what they did to Israel come some water
water I'll get you water some water okay
okay I hold the book Jesus Christ has is
a living water should I hold the book
for you should I hold the book should I
open your B is it easier no I got it man
man I got it I can read I my own [__]
I'm
trying he wants to see Trinity in the
Bible but I already showed him I'm not
talking about Trinity I already showed
him that God God had a spirit lines bro
two more lines believe that two more
lines of what I read you two lines
already you want say two more lines he's
changed Samu now where is he going back
to Samuel go back to Samuel man we can
go back to Samuel I got Samuel samel
right here it's so hard to retext bro
come on you so hard to I read you two
lines already what is what two more
please just two more I read you two more
generous you have it on your phone right
you can read it too right yeah if you
want okay I read you two line you can
read two more lines part of Trinity part
of Trinity the book of Isaiah yeah yeah
yeah yeah Old Testament as well Old
Testament yeah Old Testament as well
read it please which one am I reading
first CH 5 chapter 15 oh well he wants
me to read something else which is
Isaiah oh
[Applause]
my go back back I go back to 15 I go
back I go back to 15 the only thing I'm
afraid is your lack of intellect B I'm
afraid of your lack of intellect that's
thing I'm afraid of
you start I already there only one more
verse you can read that last verse read
it why you afraid to read it what do you
mean I already read two no you didn't
read the last two okay you said you said
three right where is that is 15 oh
that's second Samuel [__] that's second
Samuel hold
up he can't even read it from his own
phone he I even though I only got two
hands I don't want I can help
you no I don't need to hold my water
yeah I might put poison in it you never
know the infite you never know that's
what the scripture says right yeah 15
all right verse three it says now go
attack Almanac right like I said Revenge
Revenge and do what Revenge what let's
see what the revenges for for what they
did to the Israelites good what should
they do go on wait what did the am do to
them wait what did they do to them what
they the isites they killed them they
attacked them they they something
exactly so God tell them to go do the
same thing but worse good but worse
right read it
now what about to say you just read it
man I'm
reading I'm reading I read I'll go back
again I'll go back again I'll read ads
keep coming on please
skip you know on YouTube video ads
coming skip skip skip I didn't even want
to talk today all right so uh it says
now go and and attack Alman and
ultimately destroy um that they have and
do not spare infant nurse children Ox
sheep yes I know this camel and Donkey
one simple question now I dare you to
find me a single verse like that in the
Quran theith and Islamic literature I
dare you to the single verse that says
Go and Kill men wom children babies
donkey what the hell did the donkey do
okay tell me what the donkey done now
simple question inan it
says
I show
meall show me one verse in the Quran
that says kill men women children babies
demons and Devils send me location send
me location night night sleep
Jan come on come on bring me the verse
bring me the verse brother bring me a
single verse that Allah says in the
Quran do you know Quran you should know
that
go I just told you tell me here say it
again oh you do not see verse Dev upon
these Believers Allah actually sends
Devils upon the mankind can you show me
the how is that a loving God okay how is
that Ling God check this out check this
out Allah sends Devils that's the same
as killing men women children babies and
donkeys why that's right brother go
chill out brother go chill out shade
there a shade continues and says inside
them kill babies send devils look at the
comparison check this out guys look how
evil send Devils kill babies no send the
Devils to inside them with evil brother
has the son hit your head are you okay
you need to put
backwards now simple question please
show me a similar verse
that says Allah what did he say he said
Islam is Terrorism 911 okay no problem
show me a single verse that tells us
Muslims when you go to battle with the
disbelievers kill their man kill their
woman kill their children kill their
babies hey you said you won right what
does that say right there you read it
now uh what does that say right here
verse five read that and when the in
invariable months have passed then kill
them poly wherever you find them and
capture them and
wherever you find them I'm done bro and
I I'm done bro I'm done I'm done bro I'm
done that's all that's it run away from
what said I came to you now I'm running
away where you going said relx come on
bro all right now I'm going to ask you a
question no wait wait wait I answer your
question several times now I'm going to
ask you a
question he asked me in the beginning
show him one scripture
find Arab it doesn't mean that in Arabic
one second no no no let's read it let's
read it let's read it let's read it what
was my question say nothing today
brother brother brother brother I always
have a question after I'm finished you
got nothing to say what did I say said
find one look I said find me a single
verse Len to be carefully if I'm lying
that says exactly that says that says
listen that says kill men kill women
kill children kill babies now I'm going
to read the verse that he told me to
read I'm very cool look
in the beginning of
theal murder guys I
said brother you're so loud bro you're
so loud you're so loud now Allah says in
the Quran now listen to me carefully
guys and please point out to me the
words men women children babies and
Donkey so when the sacred months have
passed kill the mushriks wherever you
find them and catch them and besiege
them and sit in Ambush for them every
everywhere 19 where in that verse does
it say kill men women children or babies
wow I read it again wow so when the
sacred M have passed kill the mushriks
wherever you find them and catch them
and besiege them and sit in Ambush for
them did you hear babies I can't hear
you guys did you hear babies did you
hear children did you hear woman you
hear M he's switching it now yeah he's
fishing it now yeah all right yeah right
what dides it say show me okay here's
another scripture read that
you said find you one but don't get
excited but don't get excited two is
better than one oh two is better than
one okay which one which one you going
read in Arabic two which one which one
which one do you not see that we have
sent the Devils upon the disbelievers
inciting them with incitement where's
the babies where's the children where is
it where is it what did he say capital
murder we started a conversation with
capital murder I said that if you go to
a Muslim country they will kill you if
you are preaching the gospel that's a
lie oh wow that's a lie wow that's a lie
what give me back give me back CU I
already showed you two scriptures you're
done where the got cook straight up got
where the I'm the cook I'm cook guys
guys we can see right here now guys
don't go anywhere don't go anywhere yeah
right here don't go
anywhere guys guys where in that verse
does it say kill men women children of
oh my goodness where was it how did how
did the conversation start on where does
it say the conversation start off we we
got recorded here where in the verse
does it say children in the recording
can't find it in find it we don't have
it about M we don't have it in the Quran
he comes and cl to me we can see we can
we can see he sizzing this man some milk
we can see him sizzling get this man
some milk we can see he asked me for one
I gave him two we can see who's we can
see who's and then if I walk away he's
say you're running away running away
you're running away don't try it come on
so now guys guys he said Islam is
Terrorism yeah I said okay I brought him
a verse in his Bible I said please find
me something similar in the Quran kill
man kill woman kill children or babies
he gave me two verses one from Surah
Toba that says wherever you fight the
mush brother where's the man where's the
woman where's the children where's the
babies where's the donkey right that's
what they do where is it